primeiramente gostaria de agradecer o
professor alex pela oportunidade de
poder compartilhar com a minha
trajetória profissional e quando fez um
gol feito quando ou onde colaborou o meu
crescimento
muito se tem falado em alte e ainda
ainda não sabe o que é o coaching
o coaching
ele trabalha com técnicas e ferramentas
que desenvolvem a pessoa para que ela
atinja o seu objetivo e achei ao seu
estado desejado
ele é compartilhar com vocês uma
história
recentemente eu estive com o senhor que
participou do processo de coaching com
ele estava preparando a carreira dele
naquele momento para se encaminhar a uma
aposentadoria
muitas vezes não paramos para pensar
como será a nossa vida de aposentado
muitas não deixamos pra ver o que nós
vamos fazer a partir do momento em que
nós nos aposentamos partir do momento em
que a gente chega naquele estado mais
desejada em que estágio ausentava estar
também bem financeiramente
o que acontece muitas vezes como
profissional ou a pessoa que não passa e
se preparam para a sua aposentadoria e
desejam muitas vezes parar pra pensar o
que vai fazer quando se é o vento vai
percebendo ao longo do tempo
lei às vezes não é bom
muitas vezes não traz satisfação e
realização
e esse senhor contando pra mim então a
partir do momento me peso esse processo
de coaching e ele descobriu oportunidade
e poder dar aulas no ensino superior
a vitória dele profissional que 30 anos
trouxe uma bagagem imensa que gosta da
aula podem ensinar muitas pessoas a
ajudar muitas pessoas do seu
conhecimento e ele falou pra mim se eu
tivesse feito esse processo antes
ao longo da carreira
eu estaria muito mais realizado porque
hoje eu faço o iel e aquilo que eu gosto
é uma pena mas ainda não é tarde
nunca me senti tão bem como estou hoje
contribuir com as pessoas com o meu
conhecimento não deixamos de fazer algo
de água quando eu me aposentar depois da
nossa vida e nos a nós chegar no nosso
estado já realizados pela empresa onde
ele trabalha exatamente isso
sejam elas porque o desenvolvimento
atrelado às habilidades sejam elas a
desafiar as suas crenças crianças muitas
vezes limitam assim sabemos que vem para
nós eu seguir alguns passos
as crianças nos impedindo de nós crescer
onde ele atua nessas crenças pra
entender
juntamente com o seu cliente o que está
levando a não se desenvolver o que está
impedindo e nesse momento eu faço uma
reflexão com vocês
quais são os seus sonhos
quais são os seus objetivos se não
souber para animais em qualquer lugar
quem tem uma música né
todo mundo conhece deixa a vida me levar
vida leva eu né
vamos deixando a vida nos levar a vida
vai nos levar qualquer lugar
vamos chegar no final da nossa caminhada
e olhar que toda aquela caminhada muitas
vezes não me trouxe realização
realização do pleito
o impedindo de você
e você caminhar o seu estado desejado o
que está limitando a dar novos passos
muitas vezes está relacionado ao aumento
do fracasso
só que a gente só vai descobrir se vai
dar certo ou não fazendo e o coaching
ele prepara através de administração do
tempo através de planejamento que a
pessoa realmente consiga conquistar
trazendo essas experiências relacionadas
ao coaching gostaria de compartilhar com
vocês então como cold também me ajudou
na minha trajetória profissional em
dezembro vai fazer dez anos que eu estou
formado em psicologia ela fat
logo que eu me formei
eu só comecei atuar na área de rega e na
medida então fui trabalhando com novos
processos
eu fui também tendo novas oportunidades
na minha empresa na empresa em que
trabalhava em um trabalho físico ao
longo dessa trajetória
eu iniciei esta empresa no recrutamento
e seleção mais ou menos uns dois anos e
meio nessa área surgiu a oportunidade de
assumir a coordenação de treinamento e
desenvolvimento aumentando um pouco mais
a equipe
ela trabalhava nós éramos em cinco
pessoas em 2013
eu fui convidada para assumir também é
setor de administração de pessoal e aí
teria uma equipe de 17 pessoas
pra mim foi um enorme
eu fiquei muito feliz com isso
com essa oportunidade mas por outro lado
fazer parte de uma área que você não
conhece fazer papo maria que você tem
que buscar desenvolver novas habilidades
conhecer melhor e se fazer também
conquiste adaptar os seus processos ao
seu novo modelo de liderança
foi um desafio enorme para mim e no mês
que eu assumir então a gente nova equipe
eu também fui premiado eu posso dizer
premiada porque eu descobri que estava
grávida
e mais eu tenho aí claramente não
poderia engravidar eu tinha problemas
enfim eo médico vai ficar um tempo em
tratamento e civilmente ainda que os
dois anos e no mesmo que eu recebi
então essa oportunidade veio também um
presente que foi a gravidez e só quem
passa pelo processo de gravidez sabem o
quanto é desafiador mais desafiador esta
é você então tendo que assumir um nó
todo dia e sabendo também que eu teria
pouco tempo
na sequência logo sairia de licença
maternidade
frente a esses desafios eu busquei fazer
uma pós em herança para acelerar a minha
vontade foi na bola em um módulo de
coaching
eu vi o gol que poderia ser determinante
pra me ajudar na minha carreira
foi aí que eu comecei a fazer o processo
faz quatro anos que eu estou na
coordenação de h e 9 anos que eu estou
na empresa
eu posso dizer que ao longo desses nove
anos eu passei por muitas dificuldades
por outro lado também de muitas
conquistas
as conquistas só foram possíveis porque
eu venci meus mesmo
meus mesmo eu venci também as minhas
dificuldades diante daquilo que eu via
uma barreira diante daquilo e distante
de o realizar
eu busquei caminhar em direção aos meus
propósitos busquem desenvolver as minhas
habilidades e hoje vejo o quanto também
colaborou também muitas pessoas ao ver
que eu era uma pessoa extremamente
tímida e hoje eu sou uma pessoa muito
mais extrovertida muito mais animada de
fácil relacionar justamente porque
além do autoconhecimento identificar os
meus pontos fortes aquilo que realmente
eu tinha condição rio bem identificou
também as minhas fraquezas onde eu tinha
aqui outro a e atuar mais fortemente
para desenvolver o coaching me ajudou a
sair da sua zona de conforto
me ajudou a superar os meus limites
me fez acreditar que eu sou responsável
pelo direcionamento da minha carreira e
não deixar a vida me levar me ajuda
justamente para saber se o que eu estava
fazendo estava agregando pro meu
profissional e por meus objetivos e me
ajudou também
mais ainda a equilibrar a minha vida
pessoal e profissional
quero dizer pra vocês pessoal e tudo
processo de crescimento profissional
ele não é fácil sabemos disso
principalmente quando tá vamos sair de
uma faculdade
o ponto de partida disso é saber se você
quer enfrentar isso
se você quer superar os seus medos e
principalmente sair da sua zona de
conforto
quando você vira um homem no topo de uma
montanha
se quiser que ele não caiu lá eu não
estou no topo
estou caminhando para chegar nessa
montanha
estou me preparando pra isso
sei das minhas limitações
e sei também o quanto eu posso
enquanto também estou determinado a
subir essa montanha de agradecer a
presença de todos e muito obrigado
[Aplausos]